[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرحبًا ، أنا كيرا كريستوبال ، أنا
معالج نفسي ومعلم يوغا.
أشعر بظهري ، لذا
إليك بعض الطرق البسيطة لبدء أي
رحلة سفر في الحالة الذهنية الصحيحة
[موسيقى]
الأشياء الأولى هي أن الترطيب الأول هو المفتاح الذي
أحب أن أقوم بتعبئة زجاجة ماء قابلة لإعادة الاستخدام وآمنة بإحكام
مثل هذا
الترطيب يساعد على تعزيز مناعتك
ويساعد في الحفاظ على  عقلك صافٍ وقد يساعدك
في عملية الهضم ، كما تعلم بعد
يوم طويل من السفر ، قد يتم
الخلط بين جسمك والتغيير في المناطق الزمنية
وما لا يعني ذلك أن القليل من
الماء يمكن أن يقطع شوطًا طويلاً حقًا ،
لذا تذكر حزم المفضلة التي يمكن إعادة استخدامها
زجاجة ماء وتساعد على إنقاذ الكوكب
، يستغرق الأمر بضع دقائق قبل
أن تغادر غرفتك في الفندق
لتوصيلها عن قصد بأنفاسك ،
يمكن أن يساعد الوعي بالتنفس على
زيادة برانا أو طاقة قوة حياتك
ومساعدتك  خفض عقلك النتن
شيء بسيط مثل وضع
ثقوب Lunger في زفيرك أكثر مما تفعله في شهيقك ، على
سبيل المثال ، يمكنك الشهيق
لمدة أربعة زفير من خلال
الأنف لعدد خمسة
[موسيقى]
الآن أنت جاهز للاستمتاع  في يوم عملك المزدحم
بعقل صافٍ وقلب سعيد ،
أطيله ،
أحب أن أستغرق ما لا يقل عن 5 إلى 10 دقائق
كل يوم لتمديد جسدي حتى
عندما أكون على الطريق للعمل ، إليك
بعض تمارين التمدد  هذا
رائع لتوسيع سعة رئتيك
وتدليك أعضائك الداخلية
بشد بسيط للجسم الجانبي
وتأخذه إلى جانب واحد
والشيء الرائع هو أنه يمكنك حتى القيام
بذلك في عملك والقيام بتمديد سهل
إلى حديقة الحيوانات أثناء انتظارك في  خطوط
المطار عبارة عن لفائف كتف نحملها معظم
التوتر في
أكتافنا ولفائف الكتف للعضلات شبه المنحرفة هي
طريقة سهلة للتخلص من التوتر من
جسمك ، آمل أن تساعدك هذه النصائح على البقاء
هادئًا ومسترخيًا في رحلة عملك القادمة.
رحلات سعيدة